ANDERSON WITH THE PLAY ACROSS A
SAUCE PASS.
ALMOST CONNECTED FOR THE GOAL.
>> John: WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
SOS INDIRECT PASS
SHOT, SCOOORES! D A LITTLE MAYB
KULAK AND HAMONIC GETS HIS HEA
SEASON.
SLID ALL THE WAY DOWN HERE.
NO ICING.
PITLICK.ST OF HIS REHAB --
>> John: TANNER PEARSON, PARTI
THE RACES HERE, TWO-ON-ONE,
GOING TO SAUCE PASS OVER AND
BROCK BOESER HAS TO CATCH ANK F
ELIAS PETTERSON, H THAT PUCK.
AND JUST DRIVEP BY BO HORVAT.
CAUFIELD SENDS IT AROUND HE'LL
GO TO THE BENCH.
MYERS.
LET IT GO.
VANCOUVER.
MILLER TO THE LINE, BOESER, SHUT
BOESER, SHORT SIDE MONTEMBEAULT
HUGHES.
THERE'S ELIAS PETTERSON WITH
ARTTURI LEHKONEN!
IS THE MAIN MAN TONIGHT AND THE
CANADIENS HAVE TIED ITNG,
AND EVANS DOWN THE SLOT, PARKS
HIMSELF, HITS THE BRAKEST OFF F
PETTERSON.
GAPPING UP.
BRETT KULAK ON HIMTHE WAY ACROS.
ALEX CHIASSON HAD IT.
HE LOST IT.
NOW A FOOT HE
SCOOORES!
IT.
JUST WAITING FOR IT.
.E
WHEELHOUSE, GOOD OTIFUL MOVE.
HE GOES WIDE.
HE SCORES.T ON
THIS LITTLE FAKE SHOT.
GETS THE GOALTENDER TO MOVE JUST
A LITTLE AND
>> Bret: BEST LINETHEY SCORE!
REM PITLICK!
CAUFIELD,
PASS INTO THE MIDDLE GETS TURNED
OVER, NOT A LOT OF ROOM TO MAK